تبدأ عمليات حرق الجثث
قبل الفجر حيث لا يزال العمال
ينظفون جمر الليل
قبل
أن يعششوا على ضفاف النهر ،
تعتبر مجموعة فاراناسي أقدس مدينة في الهند ،
لكنها لم تنج
من الموجة الثانية من
فيروس كورونا الذي يمزق البلاد
مع حلول النهار  ينتظر شودري
الاندفاع لبدء
عمل عائلته في محرقة الجثث
لأجيال ،
لكنه يقول إنهم لم يروا شيئًا
كهذا من قبل ،
حوالي 140
50 جثة يوميًا
وما سيكون كل 5
دقائق بعد 10 دقائق من قيام
سيارة الإسعاف بإحضار الجثة رسميًا إلى
الحكومة  يقول إن ما بين 8 إلى 10
أشخاص يموتون هنا بسبب فيروس كورونا
كل يوم
، ومن الواضح أن الرقم الحقيقي أعلى بكثير في
مواجهة هذا الواقع ،
حيث اضطرت السلطات إلى الارتجال
في محرقة الجثث الرئيسية في فاراناسي ، وقد
غمرها عدد الوفيات التي
كان على المدينة إعدادها
نوع من محرقة مؤقتة للجثث يمكنك
رؤيتها هنا ، وهذا
فقط لموت cova ، يتدفق تدفق مستمر
من الجثث
نحصل عليها  إذا كان القارب
لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة ، فقد
وصل المزيد من سيارات الإسعاف
لإحضار الموتى
وأفراد الأسرة المفجوعين في
معدات
واقية كاملة ، يتم رشهم بمطهر
قبل أن يتمكنوا من بدء الطقوس الأخيرة
ولكن لا توجد طريقة لتعقيم
الإحساس العميق بالخسارة خلال الاثنين  ساعات
نقضيها هنا
يتم إحضار سبع جثث إلى
النقاد يقولون إن الحكومة كانت
مهملة في سوء تعاملها مع هذه
الأزمة
أنه كان من الممكن إنقاذ العديد من الأرواح
يخبرنا نيرمال جوبتا أنه لم يتخيل أبدًا
أنه سيقول وداعًا لوالده بهذه
الطريقة فعلت الحكومة ما يكفي  لإيقاف
هذه الموجة الثانية ،
لم يكن هناك
الكثير من الجهود التي كانت مطلوبة ، كما يقول ، قال إن
فاراناسي كان بحاجة إلى إغلاق كامل
ولكن الحكومة لم تفعل ذلك ،
فقد أصبح الوضع في المدينة سيئًا للغاية لدرجة
أنه تم الإبلاغ عن نقص في
الأخشاب
اللازمة لـ  قال
تاجر محارق الجنائز ديباك تشودري إن
الطلب
أعلى بأربعة أضعاف من المعتاد
طالما عملت هنا لم
أر الكثير من الناس
قال لي أن الشهر الماضي صدمني ،
هل صحيح أنك نفد
الخشب في بعض
الأماكن ، نفد الخشب من الموردين الثلاثة الرئيسيين
، أخبرنا
أن الإدارة المحلية يجب أن
تتدخل ، وكان
الموت دائمًا جزءًا من  نسيج
الحياة في فاراناسي لعدة قرون
جاء الناس إلى هنا
ليموتوا ، والاعتقاد السائد هو أن المياه
المقدسة لعصابات النهر
ستساعد أرواحهم على تحقيق
تحرير موكشا من دورة الموت
والولادة الجديدة ،
لكن الخسائر المذهلة لهذه
الآفة صدمت
الجميع.  وضع سيء للغاية في الوقت الحالي
وكل أسرة
تواجه هذا الأمر ، ولا أعتقد أن هناك أي
عائلة تم إنقاذها
حيث تغرب الشمس ، يخترق صوت صلاة المساء
الهواء الدخاني ،
حيث يتم إحضار الموجة التالية من الموتى
و  تبدأ الدورة مرة أخرى كلاريسا جناح
سي إن إن فاراناسي الهند